[Aplausos]
em 2004 então entrou de harvard
ele sugeriu em uma conferência acadêmica
que há diferenças inatas poderiam
explicar o que tem menos mulher do que
homem na academia na área de ciências
exatas nas engenharias e até nos postos
mais altos meio acadêmico mas será que a
multidão inata realmente explicar o que
de fato acontece
eu cresci em um sítio ea mãe dona de
casa cozinheira de mão cheia
meu pai é um homem de coração gigante
empreendedor meu pai quando casou com a
minha mãe e ele era viúvo e tinha duas
filhas
como não tinha televisão em casa e
rendeu mais quatro filhos dessa união
e eu sou a primeira da segunda leva a
casa sempre foi cheia
meus pais não estudaram muito mas a
minha mãe ela sempre incentivou muitos
estudos e mas como meu pai sabia quem
mandava em casa com o tempo ele também
passou a incentivar a estudar e vive de
um sonho da minha mãe e teus filhos
formados 16 anos eles me procuraram
matricular na escola e eu entrei na
escola já sabia ler pequenas frases é
escrever o nome de cada integrante da
família e isso era a sensação nos nas
reuniões na minha casa meu pai chamava
para trazer o caderno e caneta eu ia
toda faceira para mostrar o que sabe
fazer
hidrate-se quando eu entrei na escola na
região onde a gente morava não tinha
transporte público é levar as crianças
para a escola
aí eu fui morar com a minha avó e foi um
ano de muita experiência
andava atrás dela pra todo lado a minha
avó ela sempre poderia fazer essa
atividade ela me chamava principalmente
quando era fazer bolo e acompanhava
ajudava mexer na massa e ela me colocar
pra vigiar o bolo as há
eu ficava e produsa de robô dobrar de
tamanho queria saber porque aquilo
acontecia
o capitão estava com minha avó porque
disso ela na sua simplicidade ela dizia
ela colocava na massa e bolo crescia aí
eu fiquei a perdição porque eu achei
assim se eu usasse a quantidade certa de
fermento
eu poderia fazer qualquer coisa crescer
aí a minha vó eu acho que ela morreu sem
saber
eu gostava todo fermento dela pelo
quintal fazendo experiências fazer
experiências para ver se conseguia fazer
um crescendo
a minha avó além de dona de casa ela
também era feirante durante esperando
que eu morei com ela também acompanhava
provoca feira para vender legumes
artesanatos que ela fazia
eu acho que eu dava mais prejuízo do que
lucro que eu ia ter um relacionamento
sério com a banca de pastel
aí quando foi o segundo ano do primário
eu voltei a morar com meus pais porque
teve transporte público
aí eu voltei a morar com eles 18 anos de
idade meu pai me deu nesse caso
semelhante é essa que foi a semente da
liberdade porque é e ao mesmo tempo
também estou nobre o brinquedo das oito
crianças daquele sítio porque os
pronomes possível em questão de
brinquedo não se aplicava se tornou a
semente da liberdade porque quando eu
queria pra feira com a minha avó e pedir
pro meu pai me levar o carro dele
ele está vetado minha desculpa não levar
a amava tudo na garupa da bicicleta e
reabra feira quando completei 12 anos o
meu pai veio a falecer
é ele vai aparecer ea bicicleta
[Aplausos]
é ele veio a falecer ea minha mãe ela
tomou a direção desse barco ou seja da
minha avó
ela criou a gente para o mundo e com
conceito e juntos somos mais fortes
nessa discreta passou a ação é uma
semente e também uma forma de financiar
nossos estudos porque no começo do ano a
minha mãe comprava o material letivo né
planet vivo e quando precisava de
qualquer é papel a4 cartolina de
taguatinga com dinheiro da feira
eu comprava esses materiais e esse tio
ele foi uma agora é só aberto porque dá
dessa porteira
meu pai nos estimulou a ter senso
crítico de que forma essa é uma
brincadeira muito boba
ele levava a molecada pela porteira e a
gente começar a fazer a brincadeira de
contagem de carros enquanto os carros
passavam por um sentido para o outro
depois de um tempo contando ele
questionava a gente para criarem
hipótese porque estava passando mais
carro no sentido do que para o outro e
do pomar de sítio eu pude ver os
processos da natureza de perto eu pude
ver as plantas crescerem dá frutos a
terminar e que eu ficava e enlouquecida
com isso que eu ficava observando que
alguns e mails terminava mais sábio do
que outros
aí quando eu perguntava pra minha mãe
porque que isso acontecia ela do senso
comum me dizia que era porque uma
semente era mais dura do que a outra
eu levava esses questionamentos para a
escola
o porquê disso e os professores me
estimulavam a buscar resposta científica
para isso
essa escola foi a escola que eu fiz o
ensino médio nessa escola eu tive
professores que me deram assim pra
sonhar
o ensino superior tive dois professores
uma de química e um de física que me
estimularam através das suas viver
assim contando como eras foram a
experiência deles no ensino superior
principalmente professor de física
porque ele era pai da minha melhor amiga
na época e ele estava dando aula
particular para os dois filhos dele no
final de semana e se prontificou a dar
aula pra mim também
e minha mãe com muito esforço pagava
para fazer aula de redação duas vezes ao
mês
aí quando foi a hora de escolher o que
cursar a minha mãe me deu autonomia para
escolher qual curso que eu queria mas
foi meu professor de física que me
ajudou a filtrar as opções ou
tendenciosas talvez né
mas eu acabei me inscrever no vestibular
para fazer é entrar na primeira turma de
bacharelado em física do estado de
rondônia e passei quando cheguei à
universidade
gente o note lá é unir né mas é a
universidade federal de rondônia
o nome né unidos e se essa barra mas
nessa universidade foi um ambiente
totalmente novo na minha casa eu era a
primeira que estava pisando na
universidade e quando cheguei na
universidade que já estava aqui e ela me
deu o seguinte conselho
os dois são os mais importantes você e
vão dizer como é que vai ser a sua
graduação
se você quiser participar de iniciação
científica e recebeu auxílio estudantes
você tem que se dedicar eu escutei o
conselho e os esse conselho como um
mantra
a partir de então mas não foi muito
fácil porque eu cheguei à cidade que não
conhecia ninguém como eu tive que
começar do zero fazer novos amigos morar
pessoas não era da minha família mas no
final deu tudo certo
terminei o primeiro semestre passei ali
que aqueles r sofrido mas foi
entrei no projeto de um projeto de
extensão e nessa mesma universidade de
várias pessoas que me incentivava a
participar de iniciação científica in
congresso que eu pude fazer conexões e
conhecer pessoas que me ajudaram a obter
informações de como participar do
processo seletivo de mestrado mas ao
mesmo tempo eu tive professores que
fazer questão de me lembrar que eu era
mulher tentando fazer ciência que eu era
uma mulher que estava ali e fazer piadas
disso mas eu senti que aquele espaço não
era meu e ao mesmo tempo fazer
bacharelado
eu estava fazendo matéria da
licenciatura e teve duas matérias que
chamaram muita atenção que era história
da física e história de ciências
eu notei que poucas mulheres era citada
aí só afirmava isso fiz no passado
nenhuma mulher se interessou por física
que tem alguma coisa errada e essa
insegurança leve até o final da
graduação pesquisa sobre algumas
mulheres
estudei pra poder encontrar essas
mulheres a física mas levei essa e
segurança comigo aí quando foi fazer o
processo de inscrições do processo
seletivo do mestrado
atirei para a sucursal lado porque caiu
na rede era peixe e me inscrevi para 10
processos seletivos e passei em 8 com
bolsa
fiquei pasma e entre os oito
eu escolhi a uff
[Aplausos]
ninguém tendenciosa sakineh
ninguém escolheu a uff e cheguei aqui o
sangue nos olhos nem sequer fazer
disciplinas a desenvolver pesquisa mas
ao mesmo tempo as minhas filhas
começaram a cair em relação a ser mulher
na ciência e eu comecei a notar que não
gostava eu chegar aqui mostrar todo o
meu potencial que ia ser respeitado
porque o meio acadêmico
ele vende muito isso essa bolha
acadêmico vejo muito isso que não tem
barreiras de gênero mas não é bem assim
então eu comecei a ver que eu estava
mergulhada na síndrome do impostor
porque eu passei a desmerecer as minhas
conquistas
eu passei a pensar sem nossa mas eu
passei no vestibular
primeiro passei foi sorte ninguém quer
fazer física é duas vagas brigando por
um candidato
ninguém quer fazer física aí quando foi
para o mestrado
assim a a bola está sobrando se qualquer
um chegar na porta bater excitá lo e
conseguir também foi muita sorte não foi
eu comecei a ver isso mas quando me dei
conta
em nossas pesquisas nas jogadas sobre a
síndrome de postou eu vi que estava
mergulhada nisso que eu estava
desmerecendo as minhas conquistas e com
o tempo eu venho tentando trabalhar isso
em mim e ver que também é o meu espaço
sabe aquela menina criada disse chorona
também hoje é uma mulher cientista
[Aplausos]
é uma mulher cientista que paralelo
parado pouco sua licenciatura em física
não é problema suficiente resolvi fazer
licenciatura em física e através da
minha monografia eu vi uma forma de
contar a história dessas mulheres
internacionais e nacionais contando as
histórias delas sem romantiza de forma
que eu conseguisse aproximar a história
dessas mulheres
essa jovem cientista para que elas se
sintam representados sente que faz parte
disso e também o exemplo a professora e
pesquisadora sônia guimarães professora
do ita
ela foi a primeira mulher negra a
conquistar um doutorado em física pelo
instituto de ciência e tecnologia de
manchas
a pesquisa dela é de é questão de
interesse de defesa nacional
ela desenvolve sensores de infravermelho
para colocar na cabeça dos mísseis e
certeza que muitos de vocês ou talvez
até todo nunca ouviu falar dessa mulher
então eu tenho como objetivo da minha
pesquisa quebrar esses muros e levar o
nome essas mulheres para mais pessoas
possíveis e através de um coletivo de
mulheres que eu participo mulheres
acadêmicos que desenvolve palestras
rodas de conversa debates pará em poder
a essa jovem cientista do meio acadêmico
para entender seu lugar na ciência saber
que esse lugar também é delas que se em
si também é coisa de menina só mariani
tenho 25 anos para o doutorado em física
sou mestre física e tô fazendo de
estatura e físico também
o meu objetivo é quebrar esses muros do
meio acadêmico para que as meninas
jovens cientistas não seja condicionada
apenas a escolher qualquer coisa de
menino
obrigada
[Aplausos]